mes chers amis bordelais ce soir
malheureusement là que ville me prive du
plaisir d'être avec vous mais je voulais
vous dire ne vous laissez pas voler
cette élection n'écouter personne
aujourd'hui la droite fort et juste
c'est la nôtre le programme qui
reconstruira la france c'est le nôtre
nous devons remettre de l'ordre de
l'ordre dans la rue à nos frontières
dans nos comptes nous ne devons pas
léguer aux jeunes générations une dette
écologique et une dette financière
abyssal c'est nous qui avons les bonnes
solutions et pas ce président candidat
caméléon contrefaçon qui essayent de
faire croire qu'il est de droite alors
qu'il n'a pas les solutions pour le pays
il propose le contraire dans les cinq
prochaines années de ce qu'il a fait
depuis cinq ans et nous je le dis nous
respectons chaque français alors ce soir
avec patrick avec thibault et aux côtés
de nicolas florian je sais que vous
allez débattre mais je vous le dis vous
êtes des hommes et des femmes libres
vous avez dans votre poche quelque chose
d'inestimable un bulletin de vote alors
ce bulletin de vote il faut l'utiliser
et il faut que vous alliez convaincre
convaincre autour de vous convaincre les
français que cette élection n'est pas
joué que rien ne sera joué jusqu'à la
dernière minute je compte sur vous tous
je veux que la france se réveille je
veux qu'elle se reconstruise je veux
qu'elle soit plus fort plus libre plus
juste
si vous voulez traverser les tempêtes si
vous voulez partir au combat avec moi si
vous croyez à ma victoire alors
suivez-moi vive la république et vive la
france